Okay.
Let's see here.
I'm a British conservative millennial
training to be a school teacher.
How can I protect children age
five to 11 from postmodernism,
which is everywhere in school.
God,
that's a good question.
That's Freya Hana.
That was the main video I was
making today was about that.
Okay.
Teach them what you believe to be true.
Right?
Formulate for yourself.
A philosophy of education.
A serious one.
Write it down,
right.
You can think about it
as a mission statement,
but write it down.
Spend some time on it man.
Cause You're devoting
your whole life to that.
Figuring out what kind of teacher you
want to be and come up with articulated
reasons why you're going to be that sort
of teacher and then do it come hell or
high water.
You know like often there's kids out
there that only have to run into one good
adult and that will set them on
a proper course through the life.
And you could be that one good adult.
So I would say learn everything
you can about paws postmodernism.
So you're a master of it.
Decide what sort of
teacher you want to be.
Implement that,
and,
and you'll,
you'll be a bulwark against that
kind of catastrophic foolishness and,
and help many,
many people.